il ya d'abord les entreprises pour
lesquelles de déconfinement ne va rien
changer
c'est le cas de cet artisan de
fontenay-le-fleury dirigeants d'une
boulangerie avec huit salariés il a
continué son activité avec une nouvelle
organisation adaptée à la situation
aujourd'hui il vient chercher des
masques pour renforcer un stocks déjà
constitués
on a déjà démarré ce qu'on a on a les
gants en a le gel on a tout ce qu'il
faut on a déjà tout mis en place les
barrières enfin les plexi voilà et puis
les règles de distanciation donc déjà
toutes équipées pour pouvoir continuer
tout simplement
puis il ya les autres sociétés
contrainte de fermer au début du
confinement exemple avec ce dirigeant
d'un institut de beauté d'elancourt dans
l'obligation de repenser son activité et
d'adopter une charte de fonctionnement
pour le déconfinement le fait d'avoir
une distanciation avec des clients en
institut de beauté c'est très compliqué
ça n'existe pas puisqu'on touche
forcément la personne
donc là on l'a vu en train d'inventer
quelque chose qui n'existe pas a
interdit au hammam on va limiter le
nombre de vasques un sur deux pour avoir
en gros deux mètres carrés par personne
s'équiper en matériel sanitaire
réorganiser son activité la préparation
ou déconfinement un parcours du
combattant pour les entreprises je
trouve qu'il ya un bon sens dans
l'organisation des entreprises et des
commerces et des tpe
ça tourne plutôt bien on privilégie les
salariés qui peuvent être sur place qui
n'ont pas d'enfant ensuite on essaye
d'organiser la garde des enfants
mais si vous voulez les gens n'attendent
pas tout de l'information j'allais dire
d'état ils savent aussi se prendre en
main s'organiser leur principale
préoccupation aujourd'hui c'est de
pouvoir mettre leurs salariés pour la
plupart en sécurité
ils sont assez inquiets notamment sur la
responsabilité civile et pénale du chef
d'entreprise
au total ce sont près de 80 mille
masques qui ont été distribués aux tpe
et pme des yvelines